[Music]
you might think that being a part of the
Disney family would make all the cast
members best friends forever but some of
them didn't really get along
as soon as the director said cut some
celebrities even appear many times on
this list so you'll want to stay tuned
and tell the end to know who is the
worst drama queen on the Disney Channel
if you love the Disney Channel stars as
much as we do don't forget to subscribe
and please give this video a big thumbs
up today we are showing you 10 Disney
Channel stars who didn't get along
offset Miley Cyrus and Emily Osment when
we watched Hannah Montana on Disney
Channel we stopped at the pop star Miley
Stewart and Lily were best friends
forever
Miley Stewart played the role of a young
teenager who played the role of a famous
singer and let's not forget that the
star also had to pretend that she was a
role model for Disney Channel with all
this acting it was hard to see who Miley
Cyrus truly was this is why we are
really happy to read her autobiography
miles to go in this book the Disney star
revealed that the show felt real and she
wanted her relationship with Lilly to
feel real too she knew that she didn't
have to as show business is show
business but she was disappointed there
were times when she didn't think they
could ever be friends the two girls just
couldn't figure out how to get along in
July 2017 Miley's grandma also revealed
that her granddaughter attempted to win
over an unfriendly co-star back in her
Hannah Montana days Mamie explained that
Miley was not confrontational she just
wanted the girl to like her Miley's
grandma didn't say who that girl was but
we're pretty sure that it was Emily
Osment again it looks like spending too
much time together can quickly ruin a
friendship and the two girls were too
young to face this challenge Selena
Gomez and Demi Lovato these two pop
stars are some of the most famous best
friends however it's hard to understand
their family complicated story as a lot
of drama was involved let's take a look
at their friendship timeline the two
child actors met on Barney and Friends
when they were only seven years old
years later in 2008 we loved watching
their vlogs on YouTube and when they
worked on princess protection program
together it was probably the best moment
of their friendship as they had the
chance
to do everything together unfortunately
a lot of things change the year after
Selina started hanging out with Taylor
Swift's and even became part of her
squad which means that her friend Jimmy
felt rejected when a fan asked Demi
Lovato how Selena was doing she just
answered ask Taylor the singer was
clearly jealous then we were not sure
about what she said to girls life she
said that they were both busy and she
wished the best for her friend but then
she added true friends don't let their
friends or family be mean to you if you
can't trust somebody you can't be
friends with them shortly after Demi
went to rehab and if there is one good
thing to say about that moment of her
life is that it gave the two girls the
chance to talk and become best friends
again Bella Thorne and zendaya and the
Disney Channel sitcom Cece Jones and
rocky blue had the chance to star as
backup dancers on a local show called
shake it up Chicago when your dream is
to become a professional dancer you must
be ready to face the competition but the
two young actresses didn't know that
they would be facing competition in real
life even after they got the role on the
TV show we were really surprised when
bella thorne revealed that she felt a
lot of pressure and she was forced to
compete with her co-star zendaya
she said that zendaya and she were put
in a really unfortunate position where
they were forced to compete against each
other during shake it up it made the
whole season of the show really awkward
for them the two girls wanted to love
each other but they were always put
against each other to know who's better
at this and who's better at that things
needed to change for them to be happy to
work on the show this is why during the
second season they had this tell-all
talk where they started crying and
putting everything out there on the
table
that's when Bella Thorne and zendaya
became best friends in 2017 they are
still saying that they are texting each
other all the time and sending pictures
it just goes to show that talking is the
best way to solve any problem
Ashley Tisdale and Lucas Grabeel Sharpay
and Brian Evans were not only best
friends and siblings they were also
twins we would expect family members to
argue with each other and fight
sometimes and we could clearly see in
the movie that the diva loved doing
whatever she wanted with her twins
servant to make sure that she was in the
spotlight but it is surprising to hear
that the two actors didn't really get
along well
years later ash
tisdale revealed that while they were
filming the first movie all that she
could remember is that they were not
close and they were not good friends
then she admitted that it had been 10
years so they can totally talk about
this they just hated each other
Lucas even confirmed that they didn't
get off on the best foot maybe it was
just method acting but we don't think
that it's necessary to really hate the
actors you work with after all those who
play really enemies would just go crazy
if they had to stay in character in real
life things finally changed after the
third movie as Ashley told Lucas that
after they rapped she had always loved
him then he said that he loved her too
the twins were back together in May 2017
to sing what I've been looking for and
we were really happy to see that Sharpay
and Brian Evans were now old enough to
appreciate each other
Miley Cyrus and Nick Jonas if you were
already a fan of these celebrities when
they were Disney stars you probably
remember that Miley Cyrus and Nick Jonas
used to date she was a rising star and
he was part of the most popular boy band
at that time so they made the perfect
couple unfortunately their relationship
couldn't last forever and the two broke
up in 2008 most people on this list
didn't want their fans to know about
their personal drama
but the singer wasn't shy to open up
about it in seven things she talks about
him being vain playing games and being
insecure he also liked other girls made
her cry and he kept acting like his dumb
friends but the singer has always said
the 7 thing that she hates the most
about him is that he makes her love him
Miley didn't say that she was talking
about Nick Jonas with the director of
the music video Brett Ratner did say
that it's about one of her ex boyfriends
he even said that Miley wore the
necklace that her ex gave her in the
music video which looks like a medical
necklace and it totally makes sense when
we knew that the singer is diabetic as
the Jonas Brother was one of the last
guys she dated we can guess that she was
talking about him there are not a lot of
people who can say that they were the
inspiration of one of Miley Cyrus's
songs Miley Cyrus and Selena Gomez Miley
didn't hate Nick Jonas that much when
you compare it to Selena Gomez that's
because the two girls actually dated the
same guy Miley and Nick dated from 2006
to 2008 but then they broke up and he
started dating Selena
laughter she was even convinced that
they would get married things started to
get awkward when Miley and her friend
Mandy made fun of dimming in Selena's
video
the singer apologized and said that they
were just having fun
but we don't really believe her not so
long after Miley got pretty close to
Justin and even held his hand during a
performance but then things didn't work
out between Selena and Nick and she
started dating Justin Bieber the couple
broke up
and Miley was seen hanging out again
with the singer then Miley tried to talk
to Selena on Twitter but she didn't
answer which makes us think that she
didn't want to have anything to do with
her enemy things just got worse when
Miley threw a cardboard cutout of Selena
while singing the song fu during a
performance these are just some little
things over the years but it's clear
that Miley Cyrus and Selena Gomez are
not friends since what happened with
Nick Jonas it almost looks like they
love to hate each other but after so
many years we hope that the two Disney
stars actually grew up and that we won't
hear about this little feud again Selena
Gomez and Jake T on we just keep hearing
about her over and over again is she the
top drama queen on our list you'll have
to keep watching to know more about her
competition we all know that Selena
Gomez worked for the Jake TOC on Wizards
of Waverly Place
they played siblings which would explain
why the two characters didn't get along
very well all the time but we were
surprised to hear that the two of them
weren't good friends off set when the
popular singer decided that she didn't
want to work for Disney any more because
she was more interested in grownup roles
Jake criticized her choice Selena got a
role on Spring Breakers and Jake tweeted
when an artist's definition of growing
with their fans is creating content they
aren't even allowed to see Selena wasn't
a child anymore so we totally understand
her choice and Jake didn't have to tell
her what to do
as long as she wasn't hurting anyone at
least this little few didn't last for
too long five years after the end of
Wizards of Waverly Place the actor said
that he was still really close to the
cast according to him everyone is great
about keeping in touch and checking in
on each other so he guessed that he
finally accepted Selena's decision it
just goes to show that buttes don't have
to last forever Selena Gomez and dylan
sprouse did you know that Dylan was
Selena's first kiss
she even almost kissed his twin brother
Cole don't worry they weren't dating at
the time the senior was just a guest
star on their show and it was part of
the script but we think that they would
have had a special bond because they
shared that moment together
Selena even said in an interview that
she loves Cole and Dylan she met them
when she was 12 years old and she said
that they grew up to be really awesome
guys but it looks like the Sprouse
brothers can't really say that they got
along really well that's because Dylan
tweeted that Selena is too good to
follow her old pal dylan and Cole then
he added that this is just like when
they were 12 years old with the hashtag
never forget it looks like the singer
think she is too good to be associated
with them but we hope that she just
accidentally forgot to follow them on
Twitter and Dylan just wanted to make
fun of the situation anyway Selena
didn't answer so this is probably not a
good sign we want our first kiss to be
one of the most memorable moments of our
life but unfortunately for the popstar
it was faked so she seems to think that
she can have a fake friendship - Miley
Cyrus and Demi Lovato we have heard of
these girls before and they are here to
fight together for a second round most
of us don't even remember it because it
was such a long time ago but Miley Cyrus
and Demi Lovato used to be friends we
didn't really know why they stopped
talking to each other until a fan asked
Dimmie a question during an interview
for the TJ show he asked if the two
singers were still friends and she
awkwardly answered that they were just
acquaintances just when we thought that
it couldn't be weirder the fan asked
Demi to explain what happened she said
that it's life and people changed she
doesn't have anything in common with her
anymore no matter what she wishes her
the best we understand that but we think
that it's weird that just a month before
she said that Miley was one of her best
friends growing up and she is happy for
her she's doing what she wants to do and
this is her time to break out and figure
out you know what she wants to do in her
career and her image and everything
Demi is happy seeing her happy because
she loves her so much and you know she
doesn't care what people think nor
should she we think that we prefer this
last answer debby ryan and sky Jackson
on Jessie Debbie Ryan had the chance to
babysit the terrible but adorable Skye
Jackson we thought that Jesse must
really love those kids to have the
courage to spend so much time with them
and
loved them too as we kept watching this
show every week the two girls actually
hit it off as soon as they met on set in
2011 and during the following years we
even thought that they were best friends
because they were so close but then in
2014
Skyy unfollowed Debbie on Twitter the
year after Skye accused Debbie of
bullying her the fans said that the
actress had a secret Twitter account
where her co-star pushed her around and
bullied her which would explain why she
decided to unfollow her the young
actress even confirmed on Twitter that
she wasn't being rude to Debbie it was
the other way around
the actress obviously didn't like the
accusation so she fired back by saying
that she wouldn't speak on specific
people because it's unprofessional
but if she had one wish for every child
actor especially those that tend to be
the mouthpiece for Parenteau
maliciousness she'd wish for complete
contentment emotional security and that
they said I'll find the joy in telling
stories do you think that this is a
reason why jesse was cancelled don't be
shy to answer in the comment section
down below we'd love to hear what you
think and that's it for 10 Disney
Channel stars who didn't get along
offsets for more stories like this make
sure you watch 10 Jessie dark secrets
Disney tried to hide thanks for watching
and see you next time
[Music]